[موسيقى]
هناك أكثر من نصف مليون
محل بقالة منتشرة في جميع أنحاء مصر ،
فهم قلب وأرواح
مجتمعاتهم ، اسمي بلال مشاربيل ،
أنا المؤسس المشارك والرئيس التنفيذي لشركة maxep
maxab ، وهي منصة متنقلة
تربط الأم الصغيرة  - ومحلات البوب في المناطق ال
ي يصعب الوصول إليها هنا في مصر مب
شرة لل
صنعين المشكلة في الجزء الخاص بنا من العالم أن
لسلة التوريد للأغذية وم
لات البقالة مجزأة للغاية وم
عددة الطبقات بحيث لا يحصل ال
جار  خدمة عالية الجودة ما كان التاجر
يفعله هو أنه اعتاد إغلاق محله ، اذهب إلى
سوق الجملة واحصل على المخزون
في السيارة والعودة إلى
مستودعاته
ومن خلال إعطائه قطعة
تقنية بسيطة يمكنه من خلالها القيام بكل
ذلك  يمكن للتجار عرض أكثر من 2000
منتج مختلف ، والتحقق من الأسعار ،
ووضع هذه الطلبات ، ثم نقوم بتسليم
هذه الطلبات في غضون 24
ساعة ، وكان الوباء نعمة مقنعة
لأقصى حد في هذه الأوقات الصعبة التي
يجدها التجار فيها خمسة  ry من الصعب العثور
على مندوبي المبيعات الذين وجدوا أنه من الأسهل
فتح منصتنا فقط شاهد كل شيء في
المخزن وبدء تقديم طلبات
[موسيقى]
جلب التحسين باستخدام التكنولوجيا
يمكننا تزويد هذه الأحياء
بطعام عالي الجودة بسعر مناسب جدًا